bright sunshine over the centuries old
bratislava castle as Europe's leaders
arrived on friday to brainstorm about EU
life after brexit but unlike the weather
the mood among leaders was rather dim
daily it's a kazoo lupa as whoever says
the status of europe a skirt needs some
new glasses today we will meet and see
what is possible and which projects we
are still able to push forward
renovation project up in any case what
Europe should not do is to continue
sleepwalking in the wrong direction
thank you very much inside the castle
the 27 leaders are seeking to provide a
roadmap for Europe's post brexit future
but they also know that Britain is not
the only member unhappy with its
membership in the block there's the
divisive issue of migration and German
Chancellor Angela Merkel whom some
countries blamed for opening the
floodgates to the largest influx of
refugees in the e u--'s history it gets
me so can't expect us to resolve
Europe's problems from this one summit
as we are in a critical situation but
rather we have to show through action
that we can do better sighing that's the
vessel vienen con encouraging words as
leaders in bratislava are eager to show
unity and focus on areas that they can
still agree on yep I don't know yet but
our continent our union cannot exist if
we don't have a common defense system
friends is making the main effort here
that cannot be alone and it doesn't want
to play long in loop I'd deeper European
cooperation on defense to restore
confidence among EU countries that is
something the British government had
always strongly opposed but London is no
longer at the table